so starting in the United States the
Supreme Court rulings on president
Donald Trump's financial records which
he has fought so hard to keep private
the judges have decided his tax returns
can be made available to prosecutors in
New York but not yet to the US Congress
just a bit of background for you the
Manhattan district attorney wants the
records as part of a criminal
investigation into hush money payments
made to women Trump allegedly had
affairs with the other ruling concerned
two committees in the House of
Representatives they've been
investigating potential foreign
influence and Russian money laundering
the judges said that one needs to be
decided by a lower court and then we
have had well there's been plenty of
reaction from Donald Trump but this was
the first tweet he talks about the
Supreme Court sending it back to the the
lower court he says it's all a political
prosecution and goes on to say I won the
mullah witch-hunters he calls I have to
keep fighting in a politically corrupt
New York it's not fair to this
presidency or administration okay so
here's our team covering events at the
moment Kimberly how could said the White
House Kimberly I'm gonna come to you in
a moment a little more on Donald Trump's
reaction and what it actually means for
him going forward but starting with she
Albert Anssi who's at the Supreme Court
take us through and in the simplest
terms possible because I know it can get
a bit complicated but but the ruling and
also the way that the judges voted seven
to two in both cases including so that
means that Neil Gorsuch and Brett
Kavanaugh Donald Trump's appointees were
in the majority in both of these cases
the one that has gone against Donald
Trump is that the New York case that you
mentioned the the district attorney's
grand jury investigation they say they
need financial records from musasa
Trump's accounting firm to look into
allegations of financial impropriety and
privacy and campaign finance violations
and other things in relation to the
payment of hush money to two women this
payment happened in the run-up to the
election these two women's exclaimed
that they had slept with Donald Donald
Trump Donald Trump's lawyers had argued
this is harassment that this is a
distraction from the
dental office president is immune from
prosecution while he's in office anyway
but he should also be immune from from
having to hand over records and be
involved in these sorts of proceedings
because it will be a distraction from
his office and it's it's harassment it
would give up it would allow any
district attorney in the country with a
political axe to grind to start
subpoenaing documents from the president
just to just to bug him basically to
prevent the president from doing doing
his job and the Supreme Court has
rejected those arguments both on Supreme
Court precedent and for other reasons we
had Nixon handed over the Watergate
tapes as a result of subpoena Bill
Clinton actually had a video deposition
in the mornin Jones case for sexual
sexual harassment so when so they
actually you know they've handed over
stuff they've actually been deposed on
video so to say that a third party your
accounting firm can't hand over some
documents would be harassment that's a
bit that's a bit much and at that so
that will now go to the New York grand
jury but that doesn't mean we'll see it
the grand jury's deliberations are in
private and we will not see any of that
information unless unless there is a
leak but then we have the second case
which had the potential for making
Trump's closely guarded financial
records public which was the various
congressional committees who've asked
for information both from Trump's
accounting firm but also from Deutsche
Bank the better the other Bank Capital
One and their reasons oh you know
because we are concerned about Trump's
benefiting from the presidency foreign
interference foreign leverage campaign
finance violations I mean he goes on and
on and on Michael Kern Donald Trump's
lawyer testified under oath in Congress
that Donald Trump on his organization
routinely fiddled the books to suggest
yet less money to the non Revenue
Service the tax authorities but more
money to bank so he could get more
favorable favorable terms for loans so
the Congress said look we see all this
stuff to make sure that our laws are
working and whether they need to be
changed so they were saying that we have
a legend for this Trump's lawyers said
wait a second there's no no just a
reason what what legislative reason tell
us what what legislation this has to do
this is a fishing expedition
you're just trying to find dirt on
Donald Trump to use for politically
motivated reasons and and that shouldn't
be allowed and
seems to be answer the Supreme Court
justices seem to have gone in the middle
of that saying now wait a second if
there is a specific legislative purpose
then Congress has every right to get
those records but if there isn't then
then then they shouldn't there shouldn't
be a law enforcement agency as as Trump
lawyers wrong as kept saying so but the
problem is though that when Congress in
making its arguments didn't specify what
laws any of this information would
actually app in Daponte are saying go
back to the lower courts and make your
case again and be more specific and for
the judges in the lower courts to be
more careful as to whether the
information that's being asked will
really change legislation or whether it
is actually just a politically motivated
fishing expedition so can I return to
the point you made earlier about the New
York case where you said that we may not
actually even see the taxes because that
um I'm viewing everything in in in terms
of an election campaign and how these
things can influence things before
November why would we possibly not see
them because the grand jury's grand
juries are is is a is an impound
legislative function one of the many
that we have here those all their
proceedings were are in are in secret
but anyway actually it is precedent that
a president will not be indicted anyway
while a while in office so even if the
grand jury came to conclusion that
Donald Trump had done something wrong he
wouldn't be indicted anyway well while
he was in office that's just the way
that things have worked there's
necessary law in place like that but
that just is it is precedent so there
are two reasons what the grand jury's
deliberations are in private to
president Trump isn't going to be
indicted while while in office and that
was another reason why Trump's lawyers
said well why do you need all this
information then you can't even do
anything with it okay the district
attorney in New York said no we want the
information while it's fresh and while
it still exists in case anything happens
to it but we want to get get all this
information while we can while the
information is actually there hmm gosh
it's complicated stuff innocent but
thank you for walking us through that
sheer brute anssi he's at the Supreme
Court
as promised Kimberly how could at the
White House now Kimberly oh there she is
Kimberly I read one of Donald Trump's
tweets out he's kind of gone on
category-five tweet storm since then
what is his gripe if I can put it that
way at the moment what is he claiming
yeah I'll get to that in a second I just
want to put a fine point on your
question does she have because I have a
bit of a passion for law and so when it
comes to a grand jury
they're very confusing I didn't
understand it until I moved to the
United States myself the sole job of a
grand jury is to decide if charges
should be laid so the reason that we may
not see this evidence that the grand
jury can now see is because their only
job is to decide based on that evidence
they review if charges should be laid
once charges are potentially laid
against a president then there would
have to be a whole new trial which the
public potentially could see unless
there were arguments to keep it a secret
and that is when some of that evidence
may come up into the public domain so I
hope that clarifies a little bit about
this timeline because we know the wheels
of justice move very slowly in the
United States why potentially the
president could allow this to be delayed
beyond the the timeline of November
which is the presidential election which
obviously he would want now I should add
since we're talking about that I have a
statement from the Manhattan district
attorney who is the one pushing for all
of this to happen and he says our
investigation delayed for a year will
resume guided by the grand jury assembly
I'm gonna interrupt you I'm really
really sorry about this
we've got Nancy Pelosi Speaker of the
House giving a statement
is not above the wall and that was
something that was proclaimed in the
decision including two of his recent
appointments a careful you know me say
careful reading Supreme Court ruling
related to the president's financial
records is not good news for President
Trump the court has reaffirmed the
Congress's authority to conduct
oversight on behalf of the American
people as it asked for further
information from Congress Congress's
constitutional responsibility to uncover
the truth specifically related to the
president's Russia connection that he is
hiding the Congress will continue to
conduct oversight for the people
upholding the separation of powers that
is the genius of our Constitution we
will continue to press our case in the
lower courts that's what happened this
morning
earlier this morning for the 16th week
in a row over 1 million Americans
applied for unemployment insurance 16th
week in a row we have to open up our
economy we can only do so by killing off
the virus that's what's in Heroes Act
testing tracing treatment separation
masking wash your hands keep your
distance as I said that is what is in
the heroes Act
there's the scientist a Nancy Pelosi
moving on to some other issues now but
making the point that the Democrats
would keep fighting this in the lower
courts to try to get hold of Donald
Trump's financial records so that
Congress can see them as opposed to just
the director the DEA in Manhattan and
that's what you Kimberly worked we're
telling us about when I handed her up to
you why don't you go back to that yeah
well I want to build on Nancy Pelosi's
point because she makes a good one there
again for our viewers who are just
joining us we've had two rulings one
that
in the case of the Congress that they
wanted to see these financial records
and and they're not getting them right
now in the case of the Manhattan
district attorney they're going to have
that evidence being put forward to a
lower court is going to examine this
case but ultimately it's this grand jury
that's going to likely get to see this
information but we heard their Nancy
Pelosi talking about congressional
authority there is a constitutional
mandate for the US Congress to make sure
that this executive branch behind me
doesn't get too powerful doesn't become
an imperial presidency that's these
checks and balances have been put into
the US Constitution in order to make
sure that no president gets too big for
his or her britches if you will so the
Congress made this argument that they
had a legitimate oversight
responsibility to see this because they
had questions about these tax returns
and the court said well you didn't make
a strong enough argument in fact the
argument that was made was very clear is
that Congress really needed to put
forward a better argument terms of their
legislative duty and they didn't do that
the argument comes down indeed and the
argument the house was unable to
identify any type of information with
some relation to potential legislation
so they kind of got their hand slapped
they're gonna have to go back and do
their homework do a little bit more
digging have a better argument and have
it be based in some sort of evidence and
that's what Nancy Pelosi's just said
yeah we're gonna do that we have
oversight responsibilities so we're
gonna continue to do that we're gonna
continue to make sure there's a
separation of powers now quickly you
wanted to talk about the president what
he had to say category 5 tweet storm
absolutely he's criticizing the previous
administration he's saying there's a
double standard here that they spied on
the campaign and that in fact he did
nothing wrong he points to the 45
million dollars spent on whether or not
there was Russian collusion in his 2016
presidential campaign ultimately it says
that there was none in that
investigation but the president says you
know and despite all of this these
political motivated charges against me
he alleges that he says are really
people that were not going to accept the
results of a democratic election he says
it's
right of all that I've done more he
claims in three and a half years than
any other president president often
speaks in these sort of bellicose terms
very grand views of what he's done and
has not done the bottom line in all of
this right now I don't think it's moved
the bar in terms of public opinion those
that support the president probably
still do those that don't are probably
still not going to support him and right
now it's going to take some sort of big
surprise the October Surprise we talked
about to really change the trajectory
going up to the November election great
stuff from Kimberly how cuts our White
House correspondent thank you and now
some expert opinion from Claire
Finkelstein professor of law and
philosophy at the University of
Pennsylvania also director of faculty at
at center for ethics and the rule of law
she's in Truro Massachusetts hi Claire
do you know just while we were talking
to Kimberly I thought of another
question and it's possibly my most
simple question of the day but I think
it's worth going back to why are we even
at this point don't presidents or at
least presidential candidates usually
release their tax and financial
information indeed they do but this
president is taking the stance that he
does not have to give the American
people the transparency that former
presidents and presidential candidates
have always given and so this has been a
sore point both for the American people
for Congress and of course for the
president on the other side who keeps
likely falsely claiming that he's under
audit and therefore cannot release his
tax returns what's most important about
today's decision is that the Supreme
Court has reaffirmed made very clear
that the president is not of the law he
is subject to ordinary court procedures
like Nixon and Clinton before him he has
to allow responses to subpoenas in this
case it would have been quite shocking
had it gone the other way because the
subpoena was issued not to the president
directly but to mizar's his accountants
and they were willing to comply with the
subpoena but the president was trying to
use his presidential privilege to block
mizar's
from complying and here the Supreme
Court has reaffirmed what it said in the
case of Nixon and Clinton namely the
President does not have that scope of
privilege he is not able to say that he
will block others from complying he
couldn't block it himself and mizar's
will have to turn over tax returns and
financial records to the Manhattan
district attorney for the grand jury and
clear the fact that the president's own
men if I can put it that way that is the
justices who he appointed and he's very
proud of appointing Republican judges
all over the country not just to the
Supreme Court the fact that they at
least in one of these cases effectively
voted against him how much of a blow is
that to the president
this will be a huge blow to the
president that Kavanagh of all people
the the person that he fought so hard to
get the nomination through when there
were so many reasons for him not to be
confirmed has gone against him in this
case and I think that's a measure of
just how clear the law is on this point
but also a measure of the fact that
justice Kavanagh recognized for its own
position it would be extremely
contradictory had he not supported this
case given that when he worked for Ken
Starr in the Clinton investigation I he
excited with position that Clinton
should have answer questions about his
relationship with Monica Lewinsky in the
very detailed questions so Kavanagh
would have had a very hard time saying
that this subpoena should not be allowed
to go through though I'm sure that the
president was counting on his support in
this case Claire I just want to read
something to you and to our viewers
we've heard from the New York DA's
office the district attorney's office a
statement which says in part this is a
tremendous victory for our nation's
system of justice and its founding
principle that no one not even a
president is above the law our
investigation which was delayed for
almost a year by this lawsuit
will resume guided as always by the
grand juries solemn obligation to follow
the law and the facts wherever they may
lead so new york happy with that one as
they would be clear but as he talks
about the process being ongoing I mean
this is it sort of one of those how long
is a piece of string things that could
just carry on and on remembering we've
got an election in November
that is the problematic side of this
decision what the court has done is to
remand the case to the district court
and so Trump will try to make some
additional arguments at that point that
were not raised in the record above I
think he's gonna have a very hard time
with it especially in the face of a 7-2
decision that makes clear that this was
not a close call I am not at all clear
what arguments he will try to raise but
it does mean that there'll be some
additional court appearances some
additional arguments in briefs filed I
think that the district court is very
likely to take its cue from the Supreme
Court and to order that the financial
records be released to to Vance now it's
important to bear in mind that doesn't
mean that the American public and the
world at large going to be able to see
those records what points in favor of
the Manhattan district attorney is that
grand jury proceedings are secret and so
the material that mizar's
will have to produce now will very
likely not see the light of day because
it's very important to protect that
grand jury secrecy but what it does mean
is that the president and the Trump
Organization can now be more thoroughly
investigated by a Manhattan grand jury
to see if any crimes were committed
right one of your speakers earlier said
that it won't result results in the
president being indicted hmm I'm not so
sure about that if there is clear
evidence of criminality in the
president's behavior or the behavior of
the Trump Organization
especially in that case there is
actually no constitutional principle
that says that a sitting president can't
be indicted he can certainly be
investigated and very possibly he could
be indicted before he leaves office
depending on what the grand jury finds
number one rule expect the unexpected
with this president isn't it Claire
Finkelstein always a pleasure talking to
you thank you thank you for having me